[Music]
I think I [ __ ] up what happened
so
Aunt brought us these Donuts yesterday
world famous world famous Randy's and
they're actually very very good
and I got so excited I was like Hey Mama
Bear
let's split in half what do you want
what do I want and then she cut them all
in half and look
let me open it
okay
not a single donut in sight
the problem is I told taika yes that guy
over there
that when he finishes his breakfast his
healthy one with all the protein and
stuff
that he gets to have a donut and I
didn't realize until after I finished it
so now you deserve everything that's
coming towards you to you why yeah so
many times
uh there's times where we go let's say
McDonald's and we buy hamburgers
together he's eating eating eating
eating eating and then I go to get my
hamburger he goes oh I ate your burger
on accident he's done it to me so many
times and then I have no food
that's what he did to taika he told
taika he's gonna save him a donut
look
he ate everything oh my goodness
don't worry no no he didn't tell me you
want one so I ordered more
I ordered more it's coming okay you're
so rude I ordered more I messed up you
didn't save one for your mom you didn't
save one for taika I always save
something I'm gonna apologize the way
the liver King did okay
I own up to it completely messed up
and I'm gonna fix it
horrible okay but the liver King can get
away with it so can I
do you want to see that you can't I'll
blow no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no not with that guy I tossed him
I said see what you pull he's hot it's
always good he's 38. so much time
does he need to improve he's a big boy
I thought he's a boy too he's 38. I
really appreciate my thoughts
the best yeah yeah yeah you're very nice
very nice all right so what I got to do
today is fix up the rest of the gym
stuff which is all this stuff
right here
and it wouldn't have been that big of a
deal until we saw
these crazy clouds because I would have
had all morning yeah I could have took
my sweet time to do all of it but now
why would you take a sweet time your
sweet wife needs your help inside the
sweet house to put all the other [ __ ]
away like what like what literally all
the boxes that are in the house okay no
I was gonna take my sweet time you just
said you were you son of a [ __ ] I cut
your lazy ass
I was gonna take no I was gonna take
quality time quality time no no quality
time no not in a rush you know me I work
hard so I need I was gonna uh take my
sweet quality time
but now I can't because it's going to
rain soon
but the whole time there's something
wait what did you just suck something in
you cut
place
I've been dying to do all morning since
I woke up
besides the donut besides the donut yeah
is built
so he can play out here while I'm
working okay so you told me you got a
court but I don't know what that really
means is it like official price type of
thing because you didn't even show me it
box showed up and you were like I'll
show you a little bit but it's like a
like a little it's in between official
price and a real court so it's metal
hoop all that stuff kind of like the one
he has that basketball practice how long
is that gonna take because you're making
it sound like it's like an all-day
process like isn't it only like 15-20
minutes to install yeah but not things
are different when they're in a rush
because now I'm trying to beat the rain
dude it's nine o'clock that's late
already you only have to put it inside
and then just [ __ ] organize it later
all right do you have them put it inside
or do you want it oh oh you got a stain
on your pants what the get your life
together what the hell is that these are
these are uh house cleaning sweats the
[ __ ] I'm gonna do inside the house and
not [ __ ] take my sweet time on you
ah
you wanna see us and when it's done yeah
I want to go inside it's [ __ ] cold
right now it's 43 degrees dude hurry up
help me start moving oh [ __ ] what are
your hobby with isn't it crazy that
Vegas rains
I think I just I just thought Vegas was
like never rains or whatever but
actually rains quite a bit it actually
threw me off I'm like
your brain's like not as much as
California but California barely even
rains too don't change
okay to help me go okay good night
[Music]
mama
I saved the day
[Music]
I started are the originals
uh Originals of course good good I was
about to divorce you if you got the
assorted what
that's where the weirdo lunatics
monkeys
how dare you how dare you how dare you
son of a [ __ ] a day you son of a [ __ ]
look what he did
monkey
your papa did that okay yeah
but look why would you do that to him
that's what he did
these were the old ones
those are those were old and gross and
he didn't want to give you old and gross
ones
so look what he did for you he loves you
so much
oh fresh ones got you fresh ones
did you finish your breakfast yeah let
me see let's go inspect your plate let's
see let's see if you have finished your
breakfast
I know these names what is it Blaze
Blaze this guy's right oh yeah yeah you
have a whole thing thank you so much for
finishing my Donuts
tell him tell him thank you for
finishing all the donuts and getting me
a new ones
no no he put them in the trash
got them in the trash because they're so
old it's trash is this
that's a good one you almost destroyed
this kid's dreams today
oh my God what the that's the thumbnail
right there
[Music]
you're a doctor yeah doctor
okay what does the blood say is she
healthy
okay is it good I don't have bad blood I
have good blood oh this is School blood
okay
yeah why is it gonna waste it well I
think that violates a lot of like
medical codes
it's my blood hormones yeah I don't know
if you could just take blood out and put
it back away
what other Teeth did you check with that
100.
okay there's a lot of customers
gotta look at the positives you just
don't stick it in my mouth there's a lot
of germs in there just clean it
yeah
is that how you check
hey monkey
do you want to help me build something
do you know what Papa bought you
or mama and papa about you
in this big old box
yeah like a Hot Wheel
no not a Hot Wheels set
I know you do get your more Hot Wheels
you know what this is
the basketball court
got NBA moves already
you wanna help me build it outside
this looks like a relatively easy build
at the base looks like the hoop and the
Net's in there
little wheels backboard
a pull
looks pretty easy I found a little um
things like uh maybe between five to
seven foot court on Amazon it's only 100
bucks
I figured he's gonna outgrow it really
fast so I don't want to like buy some
crazy ass legit one because when I buy a
legit one for ourselves because we're
probably gonna put a um a basketball
court I think in that section while that
grass is
the usually the adjustable ones go down
to seven anyways
so I'm like I think probably in a year
or two he'll be at the seven feet so I
can just lower the legit one Downs I
only need something that covers for like
a year or two and he's been crushing in
that basketball practice account with to
show you guys
so it's about a quick little cheap one
so you could dribble around because I
see them dribbling around at home and I
think he has a passion for it so we
might have the next Jeremy Lin on our
hands you know what I'm saying
[Music]
yeah I ordered it online
the house I went on the website and I
typed in youth quartz and this came out
yeah guess where those goes
you know where it goes
could be maybe someone right there or
maybe no I need the pole though and then
we have to flip it you know where I
think it goes what I think it probably
goes here oh yeah and then you stick the
tube through the middle of the the wheel
maybe but we gotta look at the
instructions
is that what that's for I'm pretty sure
that's used to connect some piece
okay so it looks like this is the type
of help I'm gonna get is entertainment
help
oh my God oh my goodness
can I try yeah okay come close come
close
[Music]
so this is why it's helpful to have your
own set of tools because this is the
like nuts and bolt kit it comes with and
these are the wrenches that it comes
with
and
and when you want to build something
with the tools that it comes with it's
usually very difficult right because
it's not a socket wrench okay okay okay
but good thing I have my own tool set so
the first thing I find is I take one of
these nuts and bolts and I find what
fits it so I got a socket wrench on this
side you can have it and then I found
another wrench that fits it perfectly
see so now we're in business and we can
go fast
probably build this thing I think
probably like under 30 minutes maybe
like 15 minutes
are you ready come to build or are you
still playing the trumpet
[Music]
why what the Rope is the net why do we
need the net for this because oh because
basketball courts only always has these
nets that's true okay you ready we're
gonna tighten it now
yeah do you got the right size I believe
so
this right here on this side
got this
yeah
nice and tight now what do we do the
other side
can you find another piece that looks
just like this
yep smart man no tell me man tell me
all right can you tighten this for me
yeah yes yes sir yes sir good job
oh
it's crooked that's why I started over
don't take it off okay put it back on
how about this
so you can tighten it
there you go oh good job
hey you're a good helper huh nice nice
that can climb up there no don't climb
up no no no please put it in the hole
there you go no it's not in the hole if
it's in the hole it's
all over the place in the hole right in
the middle there you go there you go
that's dead center
good job oh no
ah there we go yep no no no no no no no
no no you're gonna get all wet it's
gonna be cold
[Music]
okay make sure it doesn't fall okay
okay mister okay here we go start
tightening them
this is how we do it that's where the
tools come in handy
that's how to come in handy see that
see it's good Hold On Tight
oh no it's the whole hand use the whole
hand please okay here's another one
because one more time that was two
screws we're on the second one
no the whole hand please that's why my
things keep falling off like only four
fingers it's a test oh you're gonna pass
the test you're gonna fail the test
that was the test there's five there's
five ten there are five okay
you just give me a kiss no okay sure
all right you ready for the most
important part yep here we go
here we go
oh what the hell bro it was sand did you
see the sand that came out did you put
sand in here me yeah no no I never put
it in that basket a little sad in there
are you sure you put sand in there yeah
okay here it goes oh Santa's drip oh
it's raining it's raining it's also
raining too that's good okay
there we go you want Papa because of the
rain she's here now
thank you
look mama
you see the Kenny basketball court
go go
[Music]
hey that's pretty good
one more time one more time I know you
got the skills
oh pretty close
Go Get It Go Get It Go Get It
good job hey we're having all your
basketball skills
I know
and another donut are you serious
okay go go monkey over the rib there we
what
is the ball too big whoa this one's just
hard like that let me see let me see if
I could do it
[Music]
there you go
this is a hardcore okay if you get good
on this card you're gonna be in the NBA
this is a hardcore
[Music]
here we go in the NBA
[Music]
all right so one down
another one to go Gotta clean up all
this mess and this is the stuff that
takes a long time because it's a lot of
like little intricate random things like
these little bars and I just have to put
them all away so it's usually easy to
put away big blocky things like putting
away this punching bag super easy
but the little stuff like that little
handle right there well it's dark in
here yeah like that little handle right
there
and sorting it making sure the flow and
the usage of everything is going to be
hard one big thing I have to do that's
gonna take up a lot of time is when they
installed this rack they didn't do a
good job so you see how it fits flat
it's not supposed to be supposed to be
tilted at an incline so it's easier to
put stuff away so you don't smash your
fingers so I have to take all these
weights off unbolt it and then Bolt the
other one just one notch up so that'll
be slanted but you might not tell the
difference here
but you'll see
the difference when I'm done
hopefully get everything organized I am
thinking I might even have to build a
shelf in that corner
because we don't we have like a bunch of
gyms at gym bags and I hate having gym
bags on the floor like that like I hate
having the gym be a mess I like things
clean off the ground
super organized like this no good
probably mounted up here somewhere or
something but yeah this is the
the finangling part that takes a while
so I'll probably be in here for
a few hours while this monkey dude
I'm your one are you my Barbie yes
thank you are you my Barbie no
[Music]
no
holy [ __ ] how scary as [ __ ]
I thought I was about to lose my thumb
no [ __ ]
because I was trying to adjust the slope
of the dumbbell rack like I was telling
you guys
see that's how it's supposed to be
but the people that came and assembled
the assemblers they didn't pay attention
to the render I gave because I have a
render of how everything's supposed to
be set up and I didn't think they just
probably just put everything together
the way that's the easiest it's also my
bad that I didn't double check
because I was probably just so happy to
see everything
and put away
when I'm in the middle of unpacking
other stuff that I can't really inspect
every single part
that they didn't put it on but anyways
um when I was taking that bolt out
actually on on this side
in order to push the bolt out I have to
push it through this Pole right see it's
like three inches wide
so I'm like feeding my thumb through it
and then as soon as I fed the bolt
through which it was originally stuck in
place it decided it wanted to collapse
so it comes down hard on my thumb and it
was gonna it felt like it was gonna
Slice It Off
and my phone is Out Of Reach so I'm like
yelling I'm like babe babe babe babe my
Mom finally comes out after like five
minutes goes and grabs Geo she comes
lifts it up and thank God I was able to
pull it out and I slap the bolt in so
now it's holding it on both sides
now I can fix it but that's crazy I was
like I can't believe I'm about to lose
my finger to [ __ ] gym equipment how
ironic is that it's supposed to make me
stronger yeah but out now I'm as I'm
looking around I'm like man I really
should have double checked because
there's a lot of random things that they
do so for example
I didn't even know this was a random
Bolt
that they were just like I don't know
where to put that so put that there
and when a bolt is really tight
looks like this see how I tightened it
where that middle washer is completely
even there's no space
I just noticed that under here
this is [ __ ] loose as [ __ ] over there
watch I actually hand tightened it
already
but
look at that you should not be able to
do that with your hands if it's
like torqued with enough pressure
so I'm like dude how many of
good thing I put the squat rack together
so I feel really safe
or me and Mike did but I'm like how many
other screws are not on that type
so I'm gonna literally tighten every
single [ __ ] thing so that's safe
which is why these little intricacy
things take a long time because they're
just like you open one thing you find
out the other thing's [ __ ] like dude is
that [ __ ] too look how big that Gap is
holy [ __ ]
dude well at least not can't move it
with your hand but I can definitely tell
there's a
Gap right there see how it doesn't feed
through the nut look at that
should be fully penetrated you know what
I'm saying
did you talk about your finger
rolling
all right so it's lunch time making some
food making some cooking nasty udon
what's really ironic
is that my favorite udon although some
of the best like beef udon out there is
really really good my favorite quick and
nasty well actually just
udon in general is the uh post Shabu
Shabu udon when you've boiled all that
stuff in there and then you have ponzo
in there just all kinds of stuff
together so when I make my quick and
nasty udon that is my actual goal
so I'm gonna put some of this udon that
I already made quick flash because nice
oh it falls out
um quick flash because um
I don't want I want it to be Al Dente is
that enough for you
yeah you sure yeah look at all that
do this right here like this
well I wouldn't use that spoon gorgeous
tongs smart
oh look at that udomskis
no
I ate like five Donuts
three slices of pizza sure
OJ
all right so I get this udon
so now what this doubles as is both the
protein
and also the broth so I already seasoned
it with just a little bit of salt that's
all you need and I just throw a bunch of
meat in here why is it so little why'd
you get the smallest pot wheel own
I just had two pots so I just did it
like that
throw about half of this meat in here
like this oh [ __ ] that's actually very
deceiving I didn't think that much was
gonna fit see that's unless you shut
your mouth you know what I'm talking
about just shut your mouth real quick
you thought that you want the [ __ ]
boogers go on my on your arm
pop the boogers out see put that in here
like this just a quick little flip of
the wrist you know what I'm saying
because we don't want it to be too well
done do you like it well done or how do
you want it uh not well but like
definitely not raw the way you like it
okay so keep that going now what I do is
get some of the veggies that cooked up
some quick cauliflower some garlic salt
some popcorn butter seasoning why are
you trying to act like you're like a
culinary artist I'm not is that enough
yeah
for us yeah go like that save that for
later and then mix this around is that
cooked enough for you or not
why do you want to meet purple and the
other ones aren't we've been cooked
enough for you that's all pink still
what's the difference medium rare
you know what I'm saying yeah
you wanna meet him where no
more than that okay
we'll let it cook a little bit yeah
please
all right so this is how easy this is
you see me make the udon with the
cauliflower on the side
throw some meat on here how much meat
you want
tell me you want to stop
okay now it might be too much actually
the shabu-shabu experience yeah our
favorite sauce right like that yeah all
over it all up all up on there yep and
then and then and then what I do now
is get a little bit of a pasta water you
know what I'm saying
um just a little bit
a little pasta water okay like that and
then a little bit of beef broth and I'm
saying
where the pasta water not all be beef
broth
because then it's too rich oh I'm trying
to mimic
there's your boing boils all right
there's your busy beezies okay now that
you have this now get out of my face
let's have you try it because I've
actually never made this before and then
can you try it hopefully it's good you
try it I just made it from my brain
and I think in my brain it tastes really
good
so I want you to sip on the broth
foreign
does it taste like the end of a Shabu
because that's my favorite part
mm-hmm
five minute with Papa
did you just gizak me nope you just
straight jizz out me
foreign
so I just finished the garage except for
the mat still got to cut those so I can
go in there but everything is nice and
organized now
put up those posts to organize all the
grips for all the cable machines got the
punching bag set up even brought up my
gloves might even started doing cardio
here now found a better place for the
foam roller and that corner used to be
over here
throw away the other yucky bench but off
a good bench but
got a lot of stuff done here the part
that wowed me the most is that it's
actually freaking snowing like watch
look at that do you see how much water
it's actually snowing like little bits
and pieces of solid snow with land on me
right there you see that white one
it lands and then it melts almost in
like 30 seconds but it is indeed snowing
which is freaking cool I've never lived
in a city that snowed before it's new
yeah like living this obviously
traveling but like live where that's
like my home my primary residence I've
never lived somewhere that snowed before
I've always wanted to it makes me feel
extra Christmassy and this is so awesome
I just yells for attacker to come out
hey check it out it's snowing it's
snowing and then he was like I last
calls it went back inside but this is
freaking rad man so rad
you can see the snow whoa way crazy here
I didn't see that mountain range so this
morning all we saw was that mountain
range and then there's a whole side one
and that whole
whole top end
wow
that is crazy bones look at all of that
[Music]
let me see your socks
you're the cutie
oh yeah cause it's cold out there
it's comfy cold 41 it's gonna be 34
tonight